Comment est-ce possible ? Ils ne savent même pas ce que c'est. »
Mes collègues m'ont dit, « Non, c'est simple.
Un de tes étudiants a dû les voir,
et leur a expliqué comment on utilise la souris. »
J'ai répondu, « Ouais, c'est possible. »
J'ai donc refait l'experience. Je suis allé à 500 kilomètres de Delhi
dans un village vraiment isolé
où il n'y avait aucune chance qu'un ingénieur informatique
ne passe. (Rires)
J'ai refait l’expérience à cet endroit.
Il n'y avait aucun endroit pour rester, alors j'ai laissé l'ordinateur dans le village.
Je suis parti et quand je suis revenu quelques mois après,
j'ai trouvé des enfants en train jouer avec.
Quand ils m'ont vu, ils m'ont dit,
« On veut un processeur plus rapide et une meilleure souris. »
(Rires)
Je leur ai demandé, « Mais comment vous savez tout ça ? »
Et ils m'ont dit quelque chose de très intéressant.
Ils m'ont répondu sur un ton énervé,
« Vous nous avez donné une machine qui ne marche qu'en anglais,
alors on a dû apprendre par nous-mêmes l'anglais pour l'utiliser. » (Rires)
C'est la première fois, en tant que professeur,
que j'ai entendu « apprende par soi-même » si naturellement.
Voilà un petit aperçu de cette expérience.
C'est pendant le premier jour du « Trou dans le Mur ».
A droite, c'est un enfant de 8 ans.
A sa gauche, c'est son élève. Elle a 6 ans.
Et il lui apprend à naviguer sur l'ordinateur.
Puis, ailleurs dans le pays,
j'ai répété cette expérience,
et j'ai obtenu à chaque fois le même résultat.
[« Film Hole in the wall (Un trou dans le mur) - 1999 »]
Une fillette de 8 huit montrant à sa soeur aînée comment faire.
Et enfin, une fille expliquant en marâthî ce que c'est,
et elle dit, « Il y a un processeur à l’intérieur. »
Alors j'ai commencé à publier mes résultats.
J'ai publié ces résultats partout. J'ai tout écrit et mesuré,
et j'ai dit qu'en neuf mois, des enfants
sans l'aide de personne et avec un ordinateur dans n'importe quelle langue
auront les mêmes capacités q'un secrétaire d'un pays développé.
Cela s'est produit à chaque fois.
J'étais alors curieux de savoir ce qu'ils pouvaient faire d'autre
s'ils arrivaient déjà à faire ça ?
J'ai donc fait des expériences dans d'autres domaines,
dont, entre autres,la prononciation.
Dans le Sud de l'Inde, beaucoup d'enfants
ont une très mauvaise prononciation en anglais,
et ils ont besoin d'une meilleure prononciation pour améliorer leur travail.
Je leur ai donné un ordinateur avec un logiciel de reconnaissance vocale
et je leur ai dit, « Répétez la phrase jusqu'à ce que l'ordinateur écrive ce que vous dites. »
(Rires)
C'est ce qu'ils ont fait et regardez cette vidéo.
L'ordinateur : Ravi de vous rencontrer. L'enfant : Ravi de vous rencontrer.
Sugata Mitra : La raison pour laquelle je finis par filmer le visage
de cette jeune fille est que je pense que la plupart d'entre vous la connaissent.
Elle travaille maintenant dans un centre d'appel à Hyderabad (ville indienne)
et vous a surement torturé à cause de vos relevés de carte de crédit
avec un très bon accent anglais.
On se demande jusqu'où ça peut aller.
Où ça s’arrête ?
J'ai décidé de détruire ma propre idée
en partant d'une idée absurde.
J'ai formulé une hypothèse, une hypothèse ridicule.
Le tamil est une langue du sud de l'Inde et je me suis demandé,
est-ce que des enfants d'un village de l'Inde parlant tamil
peuvent apprendre la technologie servant à reproduire l'ADN en anglais
à partir d'un ordinateur dans la rue ?
Et je me suis dit que j'allais les noter et qu'ils auraient zéro.
Je vais laisser l'ordinateur durant quelques mois,
et ils auront toujours zéro quand je reviendrai.
J'irai alors au laboratoire en disant qu'ils ont besoin de professeurs.
J'ai trouvé un village nommé Kallikuppam dans le sud de l'Inde.
J'ai mis un ordinateur là-bas,
et téléchargé tout ce que je trouvais sur internet à propos de la reproduction de l'ADN,
auquel je ne comprenais pas grand chose d'ailleurs.
Les enfants ont tout de suite demandé : « Qu'est-ce que c'est tout ça ? »
Je leur ai répondu, « C'est d'actualité, c'est très important. Mais tout est en anglais. »
Ils m'ont demandé, « Comment on peut comprendre tous ces mots compliqués en anglais,
tous ces diagrammes et cette science ? »
J'avais à l'époque développé une nouvelle méthode pédagogique,
alors je l'ai appliquée en leur répondant, « Je n'en ai pas la moindre idée. »
(Rires)
« Et de toute façon, je m'en vais. »
Je les ai donc laissés quelques mois.
Avant je leur ai donné un test. Ils ont eu zéro.
Je suis revenu deux mois après
les enfants sont venus me voir et m'ont dit, « On a rien compris. »
Je me suis dit, « A quoi tu t'attendais ? »
Je leur ai demandé, « D'accord, mais vous avez passé combien de temps
avant de vous dire que vous n'y compreniez rien ? »
Ils m'ont répondu, « On n'a pas baissé les bras.
Chaque jour on essaie de comprendre. »
J'ai demandé, « Quoi ? Vous ne comprenez rien à tout ça
mais vous essayez toujours de comprendre deux mois après ? Pourquoi ? »
Et une petite fille que vous voyez à l'écran,
a levé le doigt et m'a dit à moitié en tamil, à moitié en anglais,
« A part le fait
qu'une mauvaise reproduction de l'ADN entraîne des maladies,
on a rien compris. »
(Rires) (Applaudissements)
Alors je les ai interrogés.
J'ai obtenu un truc absurde, ils sont passé de zéro à trois sur dix
en deux mois avec une chaleur tropicale,
un ordinateur en anglais sous un arbre,
à étudier quelque chose très en avance pour eux.
Incroyable. Mais je devais suivre la pensée Britannique.
Trois sur dix c'est un échec.
Comment les faire réussir ? Je dois leur faire repasser 20 fois le test.
Je n'arrivais pas à trouver de professeur. Mais j'ai trouvé une de leurs amis,
une fille de 22 ans qui était comptable
et qui jouait avec eux tout le temps.
J'ai donc demandé à cette fille, « Tu peux les aider ? »
Elle m'a répondu, « Bien sur que non.
Je n'ai jamais etudié de matières scientifiques à l'école. Je n'ai aucune idée
de ce qu'ils font sous cet arbre toute la journée. Je peux pas vous aider. »
Je lui ai dit, « Je sais ce que tu vas faire. Utilise la méthode des grands-mères. »
Elle m'a demandé, « C'est quoi ça ? »
Je lui ai répondu, « Reste derrière eux.
Dès qu'ils font quelques choses, tu dis juste
"Wow, comment tu fais ça?
Il se passe quoi après ? Oh mon dieu, quand j'avais votre âge, je n'aurais jamais pu faire ça."
Tu vois, c'est ce que font les mamies. »
Et elle a fait ça pendant deux mois.
Les notes sont passées à 5 sur 10.
Kallikuppam a rattrapé
les élèves de l'école de New Delhi,
une école privée avec un professeur de biotechnologie experimenté.
Quand j'ai vu ce graphique, j'ai vu qu'il y avait un moyen de mettre tout le monde sur un pied d'égalité.
Ça se passe à Kallikuppam.
(Des enfants parlent) Neurones...Communication.
L'angle de la caméra n'est pas bon. C'est une vidéo amateur,
mais elle parle, comme vous pouvez le deviner,
des neurones, avec ses mains comme ça,
elle dit que les neurones communiquent.
A douze ans.
Maintenant, quels seront les métiers de demain ?
On connaît ceux d'aujourd'hui.
Comment va-t-on enseigner ? On sait comment on le fait aujourd'hui,
des gamins en train de scruter leur portable dans une main,
en train d'aller à l'école à contrecœur avec des livres dans l'autre main.
Comment ça sera demain ?
Est-ce qu'on ira plus du tout à l'école ?
Est-ce que quand on aura besoin de savoir quelque chose,
on pourra le trouver en deux minutes ?
Est-ce que -- attention c'est une question horrible,
que Nicholas Negroponte a formulé pour mon étude --
est-ce ce qu'on se dirige vers un monde
où le savoir est obsolète ?
Ça serait affreux. Nous sommes des homo sapiens.
Le savoir est ce qui nous distingue des singes.
Mais regardez ceci sous cet angle.
Il a fallu 100 millions d'années
pour que les singes marchent debout
et deviennent des homo sapiens.
Il nous a seulement fallu 10 000 ans pour rendre le savoir obsolète.
Ça c'est du progrès.
Mais on doit comprendre ça pour notre futur.
Être encouragé semble être l'explication.
Si on regarde Kuppam,
si on regarde toutes les expériences que j'ai faites,
c'est juste en disant « Wow » que ça fonctionne.
Les neurosciences nous donnent des explications.
Notre cerveau reptilien, qui se trouve au milieu de notre cerveau,
fait cesser tout le reste du cerveau quand on est menacé,
il empêche le cortex préfrontal de fonctionner, les parties servant à l'apprentissage,
cela fait tout cesser.
La punition et les examens sont ressentis comme des menaces.
Donc aujourd'hui on prend nos enfants, on empêche leurs cerveaux de fonctionner
et on leur dit, « Travaille bien. »
Pourquoi a-t-on créé un système comme ça ?
Parce qu'on en avait besoin.
A l'ère des empires
il fallait que les gens puissent survivre en cas de menace.
Si vous êtes dans une tranchée tout seul,
et que vous survivez, c'est bon, vous avez réussi.
Si vous n'y arrivez pas, vous échouez.
Mais l'ère des Empires est révolue.
Qu'en est-il de la créativité de nos jours ?
Il faut qu'on renverse cet équilibre
de la menace vers le plaisir.
Je suis revenu en Angleterre à la recherche de grands-mères.
J'ai posté des petites annonces disant,
si vous êtes Anglaise, grand-mère, et que vous avez internet à haut débit et une webcam,
pouvez-vous me consacrer une heure par semaine gratuitement ?
J'ai eu 200 réponses en deux semaines.
Maintenant je connais les grands-mères anglaises mieux que quiconque dans le monde. (Rires)
On les appelle les Granny Cloud.
Les Granny Cloud vont sur internet.
Si un enfant a besoin d'aide, on le met en relation avec une grand-mère.
Elle se connecte sur Skype et elle règle les problèmes.
Je les ai vues faire depuis le village de Diggles,
au nord-ouest de l'Angleterre,
pour un village dans la région de Tamil Nadu en Inde,
à presque 10 000 km de là.
Elle y arrive grâce à seulement un geste maîtrisé par les personnes âgées.
« Shhh. »
Ok ?
Regardez cette vidéo.
La grand-mère : Vous ne pouvez pas m'attraper. Répétez.
Vous ne pouvez pas m'attraper.
Les enfants : Vous ne pouvez pas m'attraper.
La grand-mère : Je suis le Bonhomme de pain d'épice. Les enfants: Je suis le Bonhomme de pain d'épice.
La grand-mère : Bien joué, très bien.
SM : Qu'est-ce qu'il se passe dans cette vidéo ?
je crois que ce qu'il faut regarder,
c'est que le processus d'apprentissage
est un processus engagé par la personne elle-même.
Si vous permettez au processus d'apprentissage de se mettre en place lui-même,
alors l'apprentissage est possible.
Il ne s'agit pas de forcer l'apprentissage,
mais de laisser apparaître.
Le professeur met en place le processus,
se tait, attend dans la crainte
et regarde l'apprentissage se faire.
Je crois que c'est ce que tout cela montre.
Mais comment on s'en rend compte?
Et bien, j'ai essayé de construire
cet Environnement d'Apprentissage Auto-Organisé [EAAO].
C'est simplement de l'internet haut-débit, de la collaboration
et des encouragements.
J'ai testé cela dans beaucoup, beaucoup d'écoles.
J'ai essayé dans le monde entier, et les professeurs
prennent du recul et disent, « Cela apparaît juste comme ça, par soi-même ? »
Et je leur réponds, « Oui, cela arrive par soi-même. » « Mais comment vous savez ça ? »
Je leur dit, « Vous ne croirez pas que ce sont des enfants qui me l'ont dit
et d'où ils viennent. »
Voila un EAAO en action.
(Des enfants parlent)
Ça c'est en Angleterre.
Lui maintient l'ordre,
parce que, comme je l'ai dit, il n'y a pas de professeur à côté.
La fille : Le total des electrons n'est pas égal au total de protons -- SM : En Australie
La fille: -- Leur donnant un courant électrique négatif.
La charge nette d'un ion est égale au nombre de protons
dans l'ion moins le nombre d'electrons.
SM : Ils ont dix ans d'avance.
Ainsi les EAAO, je crois qu'on a besoin d'un programme scolaire avec des grandes interrogations.
Vous avez déjà entendu parler de ça. Vous savez ce que ça signifie.
Il fut un temps, à l'Age de Pierre où les hommes et les femmes
avaient l’habitude de s'asseoir en regardant le ciel et dire,
« C'est quoi ces lumières scintillantes ? »
Ils ont créé le premier programme scolaire, mais on a perdu de vue ces merveilleuses questions.
On les regarde sous un autre angle.
Mais c'est pas assez sexy.
Regardez la manière dont on le dit à un enfant de 9 ans,
« Si une météorite se dirigeait vers la Terre,
comment ferais-tu pour savoir si elle allait toucher la Terre ou pas ? »
Et s'il dit, « Quoi, comment ? »
vous dites, « Il existe un mot magique : ça s'appelle la tangente, »
et laissez-le tout seul. Il comprendra.
Regardez ces images de EAAO.
J'ai essayé avec des questions incroyables --
« Quand est-ce que le monde s'est formé? Comment le monde va finir? » --
à des enfants de neuf ans.
Celle-ci est à propos de ce qui se passe quand on respire l'air.
C'est réalisé par des enfants sans l'aide de professeur.
Le professeur est simplement là pour poser les questions,
puis se taire et contempler les réponses.
Alors, qu'est-ce que je souhaite ?
Je souhaite
que l'on crée le futur de l'apprentissage.
Il ne faut pas qu'on soit les membres
d'un grand ordinateur humain.
Donc il faut qu'on conçoive un futur pour l'apprentissage.
Et j'ai ici -- une seconde,
il faut que je formule ça parfaitement,
parce que c'est très important.
Je souhaite aider à la construction d'un futur pour l'apprentissage
en aidant les enfants à travers le monde
à mettre en oeuvre leur réflexion et leur capacité à travailler en groupe.
Aidez-moi à construire ces écoles.
Je les appellerai : l'Ecole dans le Cloud.
Cela sera une école dans laquelle les enfants auront ces expériences intellectuelles,
dirigées par ces grandes questions posées par les professeurs.
Je veux créer
un service où je puisse étudier cela.
Ce service n'a presque pas besoin de personnel.
Il faut seulement une grand-mère
qui gère la santé et la sûreté.
Le reste vient du cloud.
Les lumières sont gérées par le cloud,
etc.,etc., tout est fait par le cloud.
Mais j'ai besoin de vous pour autre chose.
Vous pouvez faire des EAAO
à la maison, à l'école, en dehors de l'école, dans des clubs.
C'est très facile à faire. Il existe un document génial
créé par TED qui vous indique comment faire.
Si vous pouviez le faire
à travers les cinq continents,
et m'envoyer les résultats,
je pourrais alors mettre tout ensemble au sein de l'Ecole du Cloud,
et créer le futur de l'apprentissage.
C'est ce que je souhaite.
Et juste une dernière chose,
Je vous emmènerai au sommet de l’Himalaya.
A 3600 mètres où l'air est si fin,
j'ai fait un jour fait deux trous dans le mur,
et les enfants s'y sont regroupés.
Et il y vavait une petite fille qui me suivait partout.
Et je lui ai dit, « Tu sais, je veux donner des ordinateurs à chaque enfant.
Mais est-ce que je devrais le faire ? »
Et j'étais en train d'essayer de la prendre en photo discrètement.
Elle a levé le doigt tout à coup, et m'a dit,
« Débrouillez-vous. »
(Rires) (Applaudissements)
Je pense que c'est un bon conseil.
Je vais suivre son conseil. Je vais arrêter de parler.
Merci, merci beaucoup.
(Applaudissements)
Merci. Merci. (Applaudissements)
Merci beaucoup. Wow. (Applaudissements)